who was here last time I was here I know
how was okay I know that guy Rick so and
oh I remember you too what's your first
name Eugene of course how are you good
so as you may recall when I was here
last time
I came with a lot of slides and I
decided not to use them and I'm going to
do the same thing again except I think
I'm going to show you one slide because
it's it just blows my mind so when we
get to that one point I'm going to turn
this on I'm going to show you one slide
and by then I hope you'll be prepared
and oh dear
well that shouldn't be how do we get rid
of that we're just going to go like that
so well that's only half of it anyway
that's that's not the important half of
this slide so I want to take us on a
journey and the journey is going to take
us from the hypothetical to the somewhat
real to the real to the surreal so we're
going to move in that direction so let's
start with the hypothetical and in fact
I liked Andy's introduction short sleepe
he mentioned something about influence
and perhaps on the internet perhaps
using new technologies let's consider a
few hypothetical situations here we go
we'll start with Facebook let's say that
last spring or summer Facebook sent out
this is hypothetical now send out
reminders to go register to vote now at
the moment they have nearly two billion
members they among those members include
there are 72 percent of the adult
population of the u.s. so if Facebook
chose to send out go out and register to
vote reminders to their people
they could reach a lot of people they
could reach a lot of people because in
fact a lot of Americans are who are
eligible are not registered in fact I
think it's roughly 70 million Americans
who are eligible to vote out of the 220
or so who can't who could vote are not
even registered so if you take roughly
point seven times point seven
then that means Facebook could reach 50
million Americans who are not registered
to vote and could send out reminders to
them now here's the hypothetical part
what if they send out those reminders
only to people in certain demographics
what if they chose to send out reminders
just to Democrats
let's say or just to Republicans or just
to supporters of Donald Trump or just as
supporters of Hillary Clinton would
anyone know that I don't think anyone
would know that because what Facebook
sends out is always targeted no one
keeps track of which groups are
receiving those messages or those items
on the newsfeed no one keeps track
so in fact hypothetically Facebook could
have sent out those reminders to
register to vote reaching 50 million
unregistered adults who are eligible to
vote and no one would have known they
they could have done so selectively just
two supporters of one candidate now how
many additional people would then have
registered to vote we'll get to them
okay now we're still in the hypothetical
but let me just mention on this one
issue that in fact Facebook did send out
reminders to go register to vote they
sent them out on mass and the New York
Times concluded that because they're
very clever and simple what they came up
with the near
time's concluded that because Facebook
generally speaking reaches a younger
audience and because younger people tend
to be more Democrat than Republican then
in fact Facebook even if it did
broadcast these messages to everyone
that what they did was advantageous to
Democrats that was the New York Times
conclusion and they came up with some
some numbers they came up with some
estimates but in fact we don't really
know to whom those reminders were sent
okay there's example one now it's a good
example to Election Day if on Election
Day Facebook chose to send out go out
and vote reminders just two people of
one political party or just two
supporters of one candidate how many
additional people might they might they
stimulate to get off of their sofas and
go vote well to happen there's actually
an answer to this question because in
2012 Facebook with some people I know
from the University of California San
Diego published an article about a
manipulation that they did in 2010
during the 2010 election they in fact
sent out go out and vote reminders 260
million of their members on Election Day
in 2010 and they had a control group and
they did some surveying to try to figure
out you know who went out and voted in
the the experimental group when the
group that was getting reminders and in
the control group and they concluded
that their reminders on Election Day in
2010 caused an additional three hundred
forty thousand people to go out and vote
so if you extrapolate from that
published experiment if you extrapolate
from that to Election Day in 2016 that
would tell you conservatively that if on
Election Day
book had Santa of God and boat reminders
selectively to supporters one party or
another conservatively speaking they
could easily have caused an additional
six or seven hundred thousand people to
go out and vote who otherwise would have
stayed home and no one would have known
so did they actually do that on Election
Day
I don't know as you'll see we're going
to move from the hypothetical to the
real and a little bit in the direction
of the serial so we'll get back to this
now there are other things
hypothetically that Facebook could have
done to manipulate people last year you
may recall that a whistleblower turned
up a former Facebook employee who had
been one of the news curators and in
fact I met another of the news curators
for Facebook sometime later in New York
and who told me that no they weren't
sitting in a basement as the press had
reported no that was false but yes they
really were a bunch of recent college
graduates with very liberal leanings and
yes they were selectively removing
conservative news stories from the news
feed that Facebook shows to people and
Facebook now seems to be according to
some reports the main place people are
getting their news or at least getting
links to their news stories so the
curators human curators were indeed
messing with the news feed in a way that
favored the Democrats so this is an
actual whistleblower who came forth so
this is but let's keep it hypothetical
because first of all we don't know that
the management of Facebook had anything
to do that it could have just been that
they happen to hire these particular
people with these particular political
leanings right so just an error really
kind of you know an oversight you could
consider over however let's look at this
hypothetically what if they deliberately
wanted to do that what if it wasn't
an accident of hiring what if they
deliberately wanted to alter our
opinions on things by altering news
feeds could they do that yes are they
doing that well there was that whistle
oh but you know all those people got
fired and they said they were moving to
an algorithm and so are they doing this
now I don't know so it's still
hypothetical so you've got the new seeds
you've got the trending stories same
thing could be done there right so
Facebook has a bunch of different ways
to alter opinions without people knowing
that's what's important that's what's
important they even have a fifth way
because are any of you here Facebook
users and willing to admit it ok well
that's most of you well ok you know they
have a search bar but what you may or
may not know is that although the search
bar is usually used to find your you
know friends and family it can be used
for other purposes too and before the
election Facebook posted a video urging
people to search for election 2016 in
the search bar and then that would give
you a list again a feed of information
which of course they had complete
control over so they've got the search
bar they've got the trending stories
they've got the news feed they've got
the possibility of sending out selective
reminders lots of things none of which
would be visible to people let's shift
over to the the big guy Google so Google
controls lists also news feeds are lists
and Google controls lists two very very
important lists among others but two
extremely important lives both of which
are generated on the fly when you get on
to Google search and start to conduct
search the first list is the little list
up at the top those are the search
suggestions in what is sometimes called
autocomplete Google invented
autocomplete 2004 I believe and when
they invented it it had I believe ten
search suggestions and it was an opt-in
feature but a couple years later it was
no longer an opt-in in fact you couldn't
opt out and then sometime later the list
began to change initially it appeared
that the list was just showing you what
other people were searching for and if
you right now for example if you go and
conduct a search on Yahoo don't waste
your time because their search results
are terrible by the way and they're
pulling almost all of their search
results from Google okay under an
arrangement that was signed between the
two companies in late 2015 however let's
put that aside point is when you try to
do a search on Google excuse me on Yahoo
you get ten search results and they
appear to be what people are searching
for if you use Bing which I also
wouldn't bother with but you get eight
search results which also appear to be
what people are searching for you can
confirm that in fact the suggestions
you're getting on Bing and Yahoo are
really generally speaking just what
people are searching for how do you
confirm that very simple you go over to
Google Trends and you can see what
people are searching for so meanwhile
Google's list of suggestions over the
years for some reason got smaller and
smaller and smaller so that at least on
most devices they only show you four
items occasionally you'll get three two
or one there are some circumstances
under which you can get 5 6 7 but in
fact we we actually did an extensive
survey to figure out you know how likely
those possibilities are they're very
unlikely you're generally speaking on
most devices get 4 on some mobile
devices you get 5 but the point is it's
a short list
and the items on that list no longer
have any obvious correspondence to what
people are searching for so what are
they showing you well the point is
here's a list that Google controls that
we all see perhaps every day or perhaps
many times a day and it's the search
suggestions list and generally speaking
it has four items and generally speaking
those four items don't have any obvious
correspondence any more to what people
are searching for very easy to show that
you just look on Google Trends more and
more the items that appear on that list
also are customized for the individual
so that's one reason why of course
they're not going to have much
correspondence to what people in general
are searching for because they're going
to have to do with you and your history
and what Google's algorithm perceives as
your needs so there's a list and then
they've got this other list because once
you click on something sometimes even if
you don't click on something in the
suggestions the search results populate
sometimes you don't even have to click
and the results populate below so now
you've got a second list so I've got a
short list and I've got a long list now
the long list as you know goes on
forever but most people don't go beyond
the search beyond the first page of
results which shows you ten results in
fact 50% of all clicks go to the top two
results and more than 90 percent of all
clicks are on the first page so what's
on that first page is very very
important extremely important to lists
now let's get hypothetical here what if
Google were using search suggestions not
to like help you do your search although
that's what they would claim of course
but you know they're actually a business
they're not really the public library
like they pretend to be they're actually
a business and so what if Google were
actually using search suggestions in a
way that makes them more money
how could they use search obsessions
hypothetical I'm not no I'm not claiming
anything but how would they do that
well as a matter of fact we know a lot
about this that's one when I get to the
real part of my talk I'll explain to you
how we know we know a lot about this but
just staying hypothetical for the moment
how could they do this well first of all
if they know about you and your search
history and your interest and so on in
fact they know a lot about all of us
well they could put items there that
they think you're likely to click on and
that they think you want to see maybe
but more importantly they could put
items there on that list that you're
very likely to click on rather than
doing what what do they not want you to
do yes they don't want you to type your
search term searched okay this is
hypothetical of course so hypothetically
if I were running Google and I wanted to
make a lot of money okay I would figure
out how to show people search terms that
made it very likely that people are
going to click on one of the search
terms and I would also since I'm now
controlling what people are clicking on
I would make sure that the results that
populate as a result of the click or
even without a click I would make darn
sure that those results are results I
want to show people see yes what is your
name hi John you know I don't really
want to speculate about the motives in
particular motives I guess what I'm
saying is if I were in charge okay that
that then I would lose control over what
people were searching for think about
this if I let you go ahead and type your
whole your whole search term and then
they and then I let you hit enter I'm in
a tough position now because my
credibility always do
ends on giving you exactly what you want
so you always have to have that feeling
that they answered your question right
so I'm really kind of stuck because I've
depending on what you typed I've
actually got to give you more or less
what it is you want it or what it is you
thought you wanted see what I'm saying I
lose some control whereas if I can get
you to click on one of the suggestions
that I make I'm in complete control
that's just better from a business
perspective so we've got this list of
here what I'm getting hypothetically
Google could show people lists that give
them more control over what people
search for and another way to put that
is Google could show people search terms
that would nudge people searches you
know that great book from 2008 by Saylor
and the other guy called nudge the great
great book and search suggestions
hypothetically could be used to nudge
people searches in directions that are
advantageous for the company - set ago
all right now let's get to the search
results search results 10 those are the
key ones Google has total control over
the order in which these items are
presented hypothetically they could put
items near the top that they want you to
click on and again we're doing so would
be advantageous to the company and that
could have to do that that could have to
do with making money that could be one
goal possibly it could have to do with
other things - political agendas have to
do with anything really yeah I don't
again I don't know people's specific
motives
I'm just saying one could hypothetically
use search results in a way to
manipulate people's thinking beliefs
purchases certainly and possibly even
their votes ok so we've got a few
different hypotheticals here for
Facebook we've got a couple for Google
and I could go on all day about other
options Google has if you want to look
at a cool article it's a piece I wrote
for
US News and World Report called the new
censorship and that goes through lots of
different crazy lists that Google
controls and if you can control lists
Wow you can control what people think
no the Great Firewall is based is
trivial by comparison the trick Great
Firewall cuts off access to a lot of
information although all of the Chinese
students who work with me say that in
China it's very common for people to use
proxies and to get around the firewall
so but all that does is restrict access
where I'm talking about it's a much
finer degree of control also the Great
Firewall is visible you see what I'm
saying that's completely different than
the kinds of hypothetical situations I'm
discussing so far because I'm talking
about methods of influence that are
completely invisible if if if someone is
showing you a list of search suggestions
that have been carefully prepared to
make sure make it likely anyway that
you're going to click on one of them and
when you do that serves my corporate
needs you can't see that it's impossible
and the same is true of course with the
search results if I'm putting the
results in an order that certs must that
suits my a corporate needs serves my
corporate needs you can't see that it's
impossible ok so we got a few
possibilities for Facebook we got a
couple for Google now let's go let's go
into crazy land here because remember
we're moving gradually toward the
surreal but still sweeping
hypothetically tinder tinder tinder
tinder is a
a kind of a it's a matching service
mainly for people who want to have sex
with each other very popular sex I mean
and tinder - so tinder normally just
shows you pictures of people and then
you swipe left or swipe right indicating
whether you're you know hot or not right
this brings us right back to Bill Gates
and his his original app at Harvard that
got him into trouble
so that's really what tinder is it's
just a hot or not you swipe and so on
and if someone else who you said was hot
swipes you as hot then you get connected
with that person and that's basically
what tinder is oh I'm sorry
Zuckerberg absolutely sorry thank you
appreciate that okay so but before the
election a couple months for the
election tinder announced a very odd
application it was called swipe the vote
and tinder offered to help you figure
out which candidate you're better suited
for which candidate never has better
serves your values and your needs as a
voter tinder so sure enough when people
got onto tinder one of the options they
had was to swipe the vote hell you know
let us help you figure out who to go for
so of course the people who are most
likely to do this are going to be
undecided voters that's that's gorgeous
that's beautiful because we know a lot
about undecided voters and those are the
people who are easiest to influence so
over time I don't know how many people
use swipes of oh because how would I
know right but here's the way it worked
if you it has a question about
immigration and it says you know you
agree or disagree and you swipe one way
or the other and then asks another
question you know about taxes and you
swiped one way or the other time and
it's just pretty much five questions and
then it says you're a perfect match for
Donald Trump so we're still in
hypothetical land what is hypothetically
the company had some bias in
favor of one candidate or the other
couldn't they make it couldn't they tell
every single person who swipes the hook
that they should vote for Donald Trump
or Hillary Clinton couldn't they do that
would anyone know would anyone even
notice you know if they wanted to to
mask the effect we've done a lot of
experiments on masking you know and they
didn't want to be that obvious believe
me that's trivially easy to do but the
point is here's a here's a matching
service at a website used by tens of
millions of Americans which is advising
people on how to vote but we don't know
what that algorithm is doing we don't
know whether they favor one candidate or
the other while it turns out that tinder
is not the only matching service vote
matching service on the Internet they're
there they're popping up more and more
some look really really credible you
know they're nonprofits and this and
that but you don't really know who's
running them you don't know what their
motives are and you don't know what the
algorithm is doing so hypothetically you
could put matching services on the
internet including on big websites like
tinder to help people make up their
minds about voters or about abortion or
about taxes or about homosexuality or
about anything you could put matching
services up on the internet and
algorithms could be shifting opinions
literally by the millions because we
know the numbers this is what we do this
is all we do we just quantify these
effects and no one would know because
it's invisible okay I could go on with
hypotheticals but you get the idea I
don't know what was Tinder's algorithm
biased toward one candidate or the other
I don't know so remember all those I
don't knows that's very important okay
to put this in
spective what kinds of manipulations are
making the news everyday they're not
what I just told you what are the
manipulations that are in the news
constantly especially lately fake news
that's number one
absolutely positively number one fake
news and number two is Cambridge
analytic and Cambridge analytical using
massive amounts of data some of which
they kind of you could say stole or
obtained unethically anyway and a lot of
which they bought Cambridge analytic a
funded by that Mercer billionaire fellow
who is a staunch Trump supporter and
Cambridge analytic has supposedly helped
shift to the vote toward brexit in the
brexit referendum and Cambridge analytic
a supposedly also helps to put Trump in
office and that makes them who's not as
much as fake news as well fake news in
the news all the time okay we don't
study we could easily study the impact
we could quantify the impact of fake
news stories on people we don't know
bother we could quantify the impact of
the kinds of manipulations Cambridge
analytical was using which by the way is
just plain old marketing stuffs because
all they were doing was was customizing
basically you know images and language
and ads to get people to click that's
exactly what marketers do right you use
multivariate analysis you changing
things now they they had access to lots
of data about people about supposedly
all the voting you know all the voters
in America so what they claimed to have
more than 5,000 data points for every
single voter in the United States hmm so
what I'm saying is that I'm not we're
not studying that why are we not
studying these incredibly because
they're trivial
by comparison to the hypotheticals that
I just described they're completely
trivial wise fake news trivial by
comparison first of all you can see fake
news you know
there's fake news in front of your
eyeballs or you know there's news anyway
you're not sure whether it's fake enough
but you sure as heck know that there's a
human element there because it looks
like a newspaper and so a human must
have written it and some and usually is
a name of a human who wrote the article
you can see it that's very different
than kinds of influence which are
invisible to people there's extensive
research on this and social psychology
if you influence people using methods
subtle methods that they can't see
people end up believing that they made
up their own minds you can still shift
people's opinions and actions and so on
but if they can't see the source of
influence they end up believing that
they made up their own minds they have
no idea that they've even been
influenced so what's the earliest
obvious example of that kind of
influence in United States that made big
news back in the late 50s I think a long
time ago exactly subliminal stimulation
that's right and this made big news in
the u.s. a long time ago because
supposedly a movie theater in New Jersey
was you know had cut in these little
frames into their film saying go buy a
soda you know you're thirsty go buy a
soda go buy our popcorn and that got
into the news and there was a big uproar
and as a matter of fact the the the
Association that controlled television
standards at the time they made made it
supposedly they they prohibited the use
of subliminal stimuli at least on
television some countries ended up
passing very strict laws prohibiting it
in all kinds of public situations the UK
subliminal stimulation is unlawful
period we never made it unlawful here
it's still
we'll use but you know it doesn't really
have that much of an impact it's just
scary though the idea that there's some
stimulus that's affecting you and you
can't really see it and it's caused you
to buy a drink and but it turns out
subliminal stimuli do have an impact on
people but it's very very very very
small so you know if you're building a
business that's probably not where you
want to put your marketing money but the
point is invisible stimuli that affects
people you know they've been around for
a while there are there are lots of
examples there's a body of research on
this but what I'm trying to tell you is
that looking at those hypotheticals we
have now moved into a very different
world where there are hypothetically
meth means of influencing people by the
billions online invisibly without any
awareness on people's part that they're
being manipulated and you know the word
ethics is in the title of my talk today
although the use of these methods is
currently perfectly legal not because I
think anyone would say they should be
legal but simply because the law hasn't
caught up with the technologies but I
think most of us would agree that these
are unethical at least even if they're
legal at the moment I think most of us
would agree that they are unethical so
more and more I think we need to be
thinking about the ethics of what new
technology is bringing to people all
right let's move now more in the realm
of real I don't want to spend too much
time in this because I could I could go
on forever and by the way what time do I
need to stop I know it's 5:00 something
that like okay good we're running
schedule so let's move a little bit
toward the real in early 2012 in fact it
was happened to be New Year's Day come
to think of it
January 4 2012 I got a a bunch of emails
all from Google saying that my website
had been hacked and that they were
blocking access through their search
engine so until that day I had never
given any thought to Google at all I
just thought it was a great search
engine and I started to learn some
things about Google that made me more
concerned about the company for one
thing I learned that they had no
customer service department which I
thought was odd and they still don't I
am no actually they don't but we can we
can talk about it more later if you like
but it's not like lots of other
companies where you just call an 800
number and someone answers the phone and
they help you solve your problem they
don't have anything like that in fact at
one point when I did get someone on the
phone from Google she basically said I'm
really sorry I can't answer that
question I'm really sorry I can't answer
that question I said can you help me lgo
no I'm really not allowed to help you so
that's the closest I got to a human
being who was not a bot and it was an
actual person I don't think she was
about anyway and and as point if I
started to learn some things about a
company which bothered me it only took
me five or six days to my website taken
care of cleaned up and so on and it took
much longer to get it through Google
sensors to get in other words to get
their algorithm to - okay my website
again but alright it was just a hack no
big deal however there were a couple
things about this because I've been I've
been coding since I was 13 years old and
there were a couple things about what
happened that bothered me and made me
want to look more closely at this
company one was that not only did the
search engine block people warn people
away from going to my web site I
understand that right Google's crawlers
found malware I get that right so their
search engine should warn people away
makes perfect sense but also if you try
to get to my website or any of the 20
psychological
tests that are actually based there so
you know through other URLs you tried to
get into those tests using Firefox you
couldn't get there and I hope it doesn't
make sense Firefox is a product of
Mozilla which is a non-profit
corporation and what I don't get that I
don't see how Google's crawler would
have anything to do with Firefox and you
know what and then I found the same list
she was Safari which is owned by Apple
so there were things like this that were
bugging me I don't want to go into
details I just want to point out that I
started to think a little bit more
critically about Google as a company
later that year chatting with some
people about search results and search
rankings I I got interested in that not
just on Google but on search engines in
general and I you know we're all kind of
constantly wondering about you know the
search algorithm that they use and how
they do this ordering and how every once
in a while they change the ordering
which puts you know another thousand
businesses out of business and
everyone's always wondering about those
things it turns out that by late 2012
there was a growing scientific
literature looking at the impact of
search rankings search position in other
words on people's behavior this was
being done in the primarily in the in
the field of marketing because you know
where you are in the search results
depends a lot on whether your business
is going to is going to succeed or fail
right if you can get up one more notch
depending on your industry that might be
worth another million dollars in revenue
so in fact there was a growing
literature looking at those little
notches and how they impacted people and
among other things I mean eye tracking
studies showed that people's eyes would
go up to the top of the list even when
you deliberately constructed lists in
which superior results were down at the
bottom in other words people were just
hung up on the top stuff it's as if
people generally believed that what
at the top is better and what's at the
top is truer well you think of the two
books I've seen about the history of
Google all of them and all the other
artists I've seen missed the fact that
Larry and Sergey had a classmate named
Lewis Gravano who's now a computer
science professor at Columbia University
upstairs in 104 Louie's assembled the
most amazing quarter - of seminars
everybody who wrote search engine up
through the 1990s was invited to come
the guys who wrote all to this stuff
Steve Kerr's who wrote Infoseek and so
forth and you go down the list and we're
intergate subtlest
sat on the side of the room and there we
started giggling because Larry has
developed PageRank right with Terry and
Hector and quite other people and I mean
relevance ranking and this is
intermittent readable is not my area but
I certainly dialogue back in 1976 17 you
had I don't want to take too much off
track with my time okay so thing is this
relevant ranking has been around for
decades and you know you should talk to
content.lua screw Bonneville and find
out i can go beyond that nudging because
as a matter of fact list effects have
been around for centuries and they have
been studied for aiming in detail for at
least 100 years so it has been long been
known that you know items at the top of
the list have more impact than items in
the middle under some conditions items
at the bottom of the lists also have
more impact their names for all these
things and all the stuff is in rural
study but when I look at this literature
when I look at this literature I was
finding numbers that were just awful
failed and it wasn't so quite sometime
een sometimes much much later that we
actually figured out why items near the
top of these search results are so
impactful they're incredibly impactful
this that word search results produced
list effects that are orders of
magnitude greater and any other list
effects ever studied okay slow with what
I'll be able to tell you why shortly but
let me just explain what happened I got
interested in this because I saw these
big numbers and I thought well if people
have this trust for what at the top
could you use search results
deliberately I asked to alter people's
opinions about things not just alter
their purchases in other words obviously
purchasing was was the main issue in
these studies
clicks click throughs conversion rates
that kind of thing but I was asking a
different question I was saying if
people have enormous trust for these
items near the top
could we use search results to alter
people's opinions and I thought what
kind of opinions could we alter could we
alter people voting preferences for
example that was a question that I
raised so early 2013 working with a
former student in Miami was working for
me at the time model Robertson is now in
a getting education in a network science
program at Northeastern University we
decided to test this idea by randomly
assigning eligible voters to one of
three groups in one group they saw
search results which were ordered in
such a way that favored one political
candidate
notice did you click on an item near the
top of that list you'd get to a webpage
which said awesome things about that
candidate or terrible things about the
opposing candidate so some people are
randomly assigned to a second group in
which the opposite is the case
very same search results of failure the
opposing candidate and the third groups
to control their seeing the search
results mixed up now I thought that
using this kind of research design that
we could shift I predicted two to three
percent of the people in these we call
them bias groups I figure we could put a
ship two to three four
none of them using this technique and I
hey that's not a big number but still a
lot of elections are very close so if
you can shift to the 3% of your
undecided voters reliably using you know
search rankings I thought well that
could have an impact on very close
elections first experiment we ran the
shift was over 48 percent second one we
ran the shift with 63% third one we ran
I think was 39% these are all pretty
small studies then we did a national
study in the u.s. of more than 2000
people shift we got was again about 39%
we also really discovered very quickly
that we could mask what we were doing we
could hide it even in the first
experiment we ran where the people were
saying highly highly highly biased
search results a quarter of the people
in the study seem to have no awareness
I'm sorry a quarter of people in the
study only a quarter of people in the
study seem to be aware of the bodies
three quarters seem to have no awareness
we found that just by mixing things up a
little bit okay so you so I've got now
Trump Trump Trump Clinton John
jump-jump-jump down just by the mixing
things up a little bit adding in a mask
we can easily boost the number of people
who were unaware that they were seen by
a search ranking to 100% it was very
very simple manipulation to do in a very
simple manipulation too high producing
outrageous shifts in voting preferences
as high as 80% in one of the demographic
groups that we looked at we were running
experience that were all students
speaking of hypothetical and we're
moving towards a real though we're not
there yet because this is still all kind
of fancy stuff right but then we did a
big experiment in India during their
2014 election there with more than 2000
voters from throughout India great smack
in the middle of the campaign in fact
even after the voting process started we
were still burning young people who had
voted yet because in India they have so
many voters that
they they stretch out the voting process
over a period of several weeks and we
were still conducting our study and
there India where we got real donors and
there being fun part of information that
had - alerting with the candidates I was
saying I think while still getting
effect but I think it will be really
small one to two percent or zero I
thought I thought maybe the the reality
of the campaigning and the pressure and
all that would just overwhelm what
search results to do what we learned was
that search by search results could
easily ship voting preferences by more
than 20% with real voters and over 60%
in some demographic groups in other
words here was a kind of manipulation on
my way 99.5% of the people in that study
showed no awareness whatsoever that they
were seeing biased search rankings 99.5%
so this is very different than fake news
and it's very different than even what
Cambridge analytic would do it you know
where they're just coming up with the
clickbait for people because no one can
see this occurring no one's aware that
they're being manipulated at all and yet
we're manipulating them we're the pepper
manipulating them sufficiently - we
figured out looking at effect election
statistics from around the world
we were manipulating people sufficiently
so that biased search rankings could we
calculate it the currently determining
the outcomes of upwards of 25 percent of
the national elections in the world
that's mainly because a lot of elections
are very close and depending on the
country and depending on how what the
internet penetration is in that country
what the percentages of undecided voters
and some other thing you know you can
actually calculate it fairly precisely
whether or not search rankings can be
used to flip an election in some of our
experiments we were using web pages and
search results from the 2010
election for Prime Minister of Australia
I mentioned this because the winner of
that election won by a margin of 0.24%
there are a lot of very close elections
and even in our last election Hillary
won the popular vote by approximately
2.9 million votes but what percentage is
that of the total vote of close to 140
million people we can you do in your
head the point is that's a pretty close
election a lot of elections are closed
search engines are very powerful and so
that's what we began to learn so we have
done many many experiments on search
results and their power to input
influence people we've done experiments
showing that you can influence people's
attitudes about things like abortion
fracking homosexuality we learned that
if you let people do multiple searches
and which they're seeing mainly
different sets of webpages but in each
case they're seeing a biased set of
webpages that with each additional
search there's an increase in that shift
that we call minutes or manipulation
power so people who conduct multiple
searches on the same topic if they're
seeing search results that are biased in
a particular way that has more and more
of an impact on them over time we've
also done a some cool work on the role
that operant conditioning seems to play
in this effect which we eventually
called seem the search engine
manipulation effect I won't go into the
details of the experiment but basically
what we figured out what we confirmed is
that the reason why search rankings have
such an enormous effect and much larger
than most list effects is because
there's something very peculiar about
the way we use search engines the vast
majority of searches that we conduct are
of a routine sort we're looking for
facts right I go tell me about where
Rick lizanne ski went to school all
right say what is the capital of
Massachusetts and sure enough over and
over and over again the correct answer
appears we're right at the top and of
course these days it even gets up into
the so called featured snippet or the
Google box you don't even have to look
at the search results we're actually
doing experiments on the impact of the
featured snippet right now they're
running literally right now the point is
in the can in the experiment we did not
bring conditioning what we figured out
was that the reason why people believe
that what's at the top is truer and
better is because there's of this daily
regimen of operant conditioning we're
like rats in a skinner box in which
we're learning over and over and over
again what's at the top is better what's
at the top is true so when the day comes
when we want to put in something a
little different like something we're
really unsure about like what's the best
vacation spot in the United States so
there's no clear answer right
it doesn't matter we're going to trust
because of all that conditioning that
never stops we're going to trust what's
at the top more than we trust things
that are down lower it's it's really
that simple in the experiment we did we
actually manipulated people's trust
level to show that if you interfere with
that operant conditioning in fact people
don't trust what's at the top so so much
and they start looking lower and they
start going to subsequent pages of
search results so we also have done a
series of experiments so it'll be
published soon and looking at the way
seem can be suppressed with various
kinds of alerts and there are people
interested in this because for example
you may be familiar with the project
called find X anyone know find X it's a
new projects based in Europe the in fact
the man who started this is now working
with me and some other people on
something I'll mention at the end of the
talk and
find X's is meant to be a search engine
which is which is transparent and fair
in which the rules for ordering you know
are may are made public and in which
even users have have a say actually in
determining what the algorithm is doing
and how it's computing search results
and another thing they are thinking
about is adding alerts I mean if you add
alerts saying you know this this this
set of results appears to be you know to
favor Hillary Clinton that some has an
impact on the way people treat what's in
the search results you can also add
alerts to particular you know items in
the list so we have work coming out on
that so we're moving gradually toward
the real here we also started last year
studying search suggestions now again
we're studying things that are invisible
we're not interested in fake news yeah
yes I think but I have a question yes is
there a group of people who are somewhat
immune to these effects you describe in
other words everybody is affected by
those well in the size of John the
United States we've never found any well
I mean if there's going to be
individuals or a me and of course but we
have never found a demographic
resistance I'm talking individual
instead an individual biologically
possible who would not be affected well
as far as anyone who is very by nature
very skeptical or anyone who's had a bad
experience with Google or something I'm
sure of course individual is a little
book people vlogging you because I don't
think so we got all the same well as I
say we in the United States we have
never found a demographic group that was
immune never great so because it's a
question of how much people are slaves
that this much or isn't this much but I
mean it's crazy
everybody's
if everybody is swayed a little bit how
can they talk about facts any fake news
if the content producers and content
consumers also are influenced by other
people's opinion so everything is ready
well that they ever come Lincoln you can
fool all the people some of the time
some of the people all the time no no
I'm not cooking oh well let me just
point out that you know we know how to
suppress these effects so in the paper
that we have coming out we actually show
as you can suppress these in our control
groups we suppress the effect completely
100% so we know how to suppress this
kind of effect you know if you mix
things up okay then people don't shift
one way or the other so and there are
other ways to suppress the effect in
varying degrees so we're learning about
that let me just shift over to search
suggestions quickly because we now have
learned a lot
okay Ramez major we've now learned a lot
about search suggestions and why we're
seeing the search suggestions we're
seeing why generally speaking we're only
saying four we actually I mean really
have learned so much about this that
again it's like it's a whole scary area
so we've named a new effect for the
search suggestion effect because search
suggestions can in fact be used easily
to manipulate people's opinions
attitudes beliefs behaviors voting
preferences we've even figured out where
the number four comes from and the key
there to put it this briefly the key to
that number four has to do with what
happens with negative search suggestions
you forget negativity bias I'm sure
because people study it in a half a
dozen different fields sometimes it's
called the cockroach in the salad
phenomenon you know when there's
something negative and then when a
stimulus is negative like a cockroach in
your salad your attention is drawn to it
and it ruins the whole sale and you tend
to settle back now if I put a piece of
chocolate into a plate of sewage that
does not upgrade the plate of sewage at
all but you know something particular
about negatives well it turns out our
new experiments show that there's
something very special about those
negative
in the list of search suggestions - and
guess who knows that Google so in June
July and August of last year we
documented the fact this was partly
based on a video that had gone viral in
June then in fact Google is
systematically suppressing negative
search suggestions for Hillary Clinton
now when we went public with that and
others went public with that it wasn't
just us but when we went public with our
findings Google flipped the switch they
literally just turn off the manipulation
just like that and from that day on you
could start to see negatives when you
did searches for anything related to
Hillary Clinton but June July in August
it was virtually impossible to get any
negative search suggestions we've
learned that when there's a negative in
that list of four it can draw 10 to 15
times as many clicks and the more
undecided someone is on an issue the
more clicks the negative draws so one of
the simplest ways to manipulate people's
opinions invisibly is through the
differential suppression of negative
search suggestions that is to say I
suppress the negative search suggestions
for the position I'm supporting and I
allow negative search suggestions to
appear for the other position when I'm
not supporting and what we're now doing
is quantifying what that does to people
searches and what that does to people's
opinions and voting preferences we're
doing that right now but we even figured
out that number four because it turned
out that if there is a negative in the
list and I and I add more and more
alternatives to that negative do I want
people clicking on that negative believe
me I'm allowing that negative to be
there because I want people to click on
it and I know it attracts attention they
know it attracts quick but the more
alternatives I add the fewer people will
click on the negative it dilutes the
impact of the negativity box right now
by the same token I want to keep adding
more items to my list why because I
don't want people finishing to type
finishing their own search terms I don't
want them doing that so
on the one hand I want my list to be
long on the other hand I want it to be
short well it turns out those two
distributions overlap perfectly with one
optimal value guess what it is o4 is the
magic number we didn't know if this was
going to come out of our data but it
popped right out okay
so we're learning more and more about
how these things work now we get to it's
surreal you know all this stuff even in
experiments even the experiment in India
in some sense it's all hypothetical
isn't it because you don't know what
people are really seeing I mean to see
what people are really seeing I have to
creep up behind Eugene like this and I'd
have to look over his shoulder and go
are there any European nations that we
practiced that were practically
unaffected by the two world wars now I
know because I crept up on him and I
looked over his shoulder and wouldn't we
have to do that to really see what
people are seeing so I tell the story
the full story is coming out in a couple
months and a piece called caming big
tech and I recommend it to high because
I'm told by friends who've read it that
it reads like a spy novel and I tell a
story of what's this crazy thing we did
so now we're in the surreal realm here
starting in late 2015 early 2016 we set
up a meal Tsin type network of field
agents around the country all these
people were recruited in a clandestine
manner we took incredible steps to make
sure that they could not be identified
this which Nielsen those two Nielsen
that was saying was it's the families I
used to rate television shows I've been
doing that since the night since 1950s
so we recruited these people we
developed a custom add-on for both
Firefox and Chrome that all of these are
field agents
all on their computers that gave us
control over information that we would
be collecting automatically when they
conducted searches and to in particular
searches using any one of 500 different
election related search terms that we
control we go through that list
sometimes we could collect whatever we
wanted but as it happens we were only
collecting information about election
related searches and we've got our first
data starting to come in on May 19 2016
and we kept going up to the election and
as we worked out the kinks in our system
the rate of data flow increased and
ultimately we preserved thirteen
thousand two hundred and seven searches
on Google Bing and Yahoo and the ninety
eight thousand forty four web pages to
which the search results linked and of
course we knew what search positions the
links were appearing in so in other
words we had the ability to determine we
were not looking over the shoulders of
our fuel agents as they were conducting
searches and preserving their actual
search results and preserving the
webpages to which all ten search results
on the first page linked so this had
never been done before apparently and it
was tremendously exciting and it was
very nerve wracking we man used
crowdsourcing to determine whether or
the webpages were favored Hillary
Clinton or Donald Trump and we concluded
that in fact for roughly over nearly six
months before the election and Google's
search rankings were biased in favor of
Hillary Clinton we also determined that
the bias in Google's search results was
larger than the bias in Yahoo's search
results which was much much smaller and
of course the fact that they have a bias
shouldn't be too surprising since
they're pulling almost all of their
search results from Google and then
learn about Bing well it turns out we
couldn't use our being data they're a
bunch of data we couldn't use why
some of our field agents were commuting
for communicating with us using Gmail we
deliberately recruited a few violations
deliberately who use Gmail because we
knew that if Google took an interest in
what we were doing it would be very easy
for them to identify those people so
that was kind of our control group so
that brings me finally to the one slide
I'm going to show you now is this real
or surreal
this is showing you over twenty five day
period
before November 8th and including the
membrane this is showing you the bias if
any of those points above the line is
showing bias in favor or favoritism for
Hillary Clinton is pro Clinton below the
line that would be webpages favored
Donald Trump so this is showing you 25
days before the election and you see
there are pretty clear favoritism for
Hillary Clinton in search results and by
the way it said nothing to the search
terms because if you look at the search
terms people were using the search terms
actually slightly favored Donald Trump
so this was not an effective search
terms this is an algorithmic effect and
now this is what's cool these are all
non Gmail Google users what about that
control group we had what about the
Google users who are also communicating
with us during all these months using
Gmail
now to my eye those graphs look
different statistically those numbers
are dramatically different at the point
0:01 level they're dramatically
different you can draw whatever
conclusions you like regarding why we
got this difference but what this tells
me is when you're going to conduct a
study like this you should be very
cautious but much how you conduct the
study what we realized at the end of all
this was not so much that our numbers
really were very important what we
realize is that we have the ability now
to look over people's shoulders as
they're looking at tinder and they're
swiping as they're using Facebook as
they're looking at Facebook feeds as
they're looking at not just search
rankings as they're looking at search
suggestions you can use the same the
same add-on technology that we've
successfully developed here in this
project to look over people's shoulders
around the world you can scale up what
we did and and set it up in country
after country after country and so when
we realized that this was possible what
we really had here a way of keeping tabs
on these big tech companies and what
they're showing people then I caught up
some people I knew including one of
these guys over here and guys some of
you know named Dennis Allison and some
other nice folks of Jake Shapiro from
Princeton University and Martin Moore
from King's College London and on and on
and on the list now is growing and
growing and growing of people at major
institutions who've become part of a
group that is working to set up a new
organization is called the sunlight
society and the sunlight society will
serve as a kind of monitor of
technologies that are being developed
which could in fact influence people's
behaviors people
opinions people's votes people's
purchases perhaps without them even
knowing this kind of system whether we
do it successfully or not it needs to
exist there's definitely a need for this
at this point because everything that
I've been saying up until just a few
minutes ago was all hypothetical wasn't
it this is not so hypothetical anymore
this is much closer to real or even
surreal this is weird you can use this
technology to look at demographic
effects to look at you know what these
companies are showing people how
individualized you know these are the
these the stimuli are that people are
being subjected to you could look at
anything that people are seeing on their
screens have it instantly transmitted
which to servers which is what we did
have your servers do an analysis and
we're now working on automating the
analysis of bias ratings for example and
all of that stuff can be automated you
can train algorithms you know to
evaluate text in much the same way that
humans evaluate text and those
algorithms are getting better and better
and better and in fact both Google and
Facebook right now are using algorithms
like that to try to identify fake news
stories the point is you could be
collecting data in real time on many
different platforms analyzing the data
in real time and finding the problems
maybe before they get out of hand you
could share these findings as
appropriate with the media you could
share them as appropriate with law
enforcement agencies courts I had a
conference call a couple of weeks ago
with the two top investigators in the
three antitrust actions that the EU has
brought against Google they're very
interested in this kind of technology
because the evidence they have for to
support some of the claims that they
have made again
Google is actually pretty weak compared
to what we have so I think we're I think
we're there and we've gone from
hypothetical to a little bit more real
but still somewhat hypothetical to a lot
more real and then the possibility of
really finally being able to make
companies like this accountable to the
public if this interests you and you'd
like to help you know join this effort
again whether we do it successfully or
not we know it's going to happen and we
know it needs to happen and that's my
story thank you so given the two
examples that gave of Facebook and
Google and even the power container I'm
sorry and gender and yeah that's this
side too so powerful as you say why did
Donna from Quinn well he wanted because
they'll kill her either the electoral
college and the American people didn't
choose him I mean Hillary Clinton won by
almost 2.9 million votes run the popular
vote maybe in California with Nothings
of it that's that's irrelevance I mean
if we if we had a direct vote kind of
system which they have in many countries
then she would have won I you know the
analysis of that election when people
are going to be analyzing that election
400 years and we all know there's a long
list of reasons why Donald Trump won but
I will tell you and I guess it's on the
record because I'm being recorded I will
tell you that then I am a friend of some
people in the Trump family and then I
was in touch with them on election eve
and that there came a certain moment in
time until he make that time where I got
a text and the text said
we are all shocked here and when this
person said we this person minute we see
what I'm saying they had absolutely not
only did they not believe that we're
going to win
I personally don't think based on again
my personal knowledge of some of the
people involved I personally do not
believe he had any intention of becoming
president which is why he is still
looking very much like a deer in the
headlights he was trying to increase his
his celebrity status he was trying to to
lay the foundations for setting up a
huge media network and he was putting
all those pieces in place and this is
not what these people had in mind which
is why they're kind of salt scurrying
around and there's just complete chaos
and you know so he won because of what
historians will tell us 50 years from
now that's why he won see what I'm
saying
just like Google Facebook today well you
know there's the question again
hypotheticals right the question is was
Google using and what's Facebook using
these manipulations to the full extent
that they had thought that was public
and we have reason to believe that they
were not I mean we know for example that
Google turned off that negative search
suggestion manipulation in early
September
we know they just turned it right off I
bet so I think that that the companies
that you know behind the scenes or in
some cases very openly were you know
wanted Hillary Clinton to win we're
supporting her in all kinds of ways I
mean Dustin Dustin Moskowitz my
pronouncing that correctly one of the
cofounders of Facebook he donated it
just a couple of months before the
election donated twenty five million
dollars to the Democrats so you know
these companies and the people that work
for these companies they were very
strong supporters of the press but I
think number one I think that they held
back a little bit on the manipulations
and number two I think I think that they
were just overconfident I think they're
over continent they the polls said
consistently that she had it in the bag
and I think they just got overconfident
and maybe we're doing a little clashes
and I don't think that they used all the
tools that they had available to them
but that's why you have to have a
monitoring system in place because you
the historians are just going to be
speculating we don't need to speculate
we can monitor we can track they track
us
we can track none it's that simple
and then this won't be speculation with
lice and plants it's all speculation
there was an article that came out in
The Guardian which has done a very very
good series on height action and very
skeptical about you know what's what
high tech is serving up to the world was
thirty peace in early December talking
about the brexit issue and this is by
Carol cut cut Wallander my expectantly
the number of times very very very very
smart journalists and good investigative
journalist and in this article she
laments the fact that what people in the
UK were seeing on their computer screens
you know back in June when the breakfast
book occurred that it was all lost that
we can't know what Cambridge analytical
was showing people because it's all lost
it's all ephemeral right most of what we
see on the screen is ephemeral
especially one word generated search
result it's ephemeral it exists for a
couple seconds and it has an impact on
that's going to goes away it's gone
so what she was saying was if only if
only we could go back in time and see
what people were seeing on their screens
okay we could do that I I have an
appointment on Friday with folks from
the Internet Archive not far from here
which is saying a Brewster cael's
project and you know the basement
following what we've been doing since
almost almost at the beginning because
at some point the Internet Archive is
going to post our database for everyone
to you know pour through
but I mean that's what we need we need
organizations like the Internet Archive
working with people who develop
monitoring systems an organization like
this unlike society that not only
develops and and scaled up these systems
but that looks around the world for
other people developing similar systems
and kind of coordinates coordinates the
efforts and this now we don't have to
speculate we'll know what's happening
and this could result in something
wonderful it could actually get some of
these manipulations to disappear it's
possible if it's a good monitoring
system or in place that some of these
companies were doing some of these crazy
things
think about swipe the boat will stop
because they'll realize this is being
recorded this is being recorded yes what
is your name Brad now are you wanted to
be famous or infamous actual students I
guess I guess Wow well that has not been
here too many times
well thank you for coming Brandon thanks
again yeah this is definitely quite
interesting I'm like curious to see more
of this data and need for it is like
it's definitely very clear it's less
clear to be like how we can actually be
interpreting these results right now
anyway without having more of it just
because like for one difference right
off the bat with like Gmail users
through all we've logged into your
Google search result like that's a
completely different set of
personalization and development going on
at Google right be showing you that you
know which results those are right
that's just like already a difference
there and then just thinking about how
you mess I need the hardest parts are
more fundamentally like how do you
measure what is a bias better search
result let's see Brad I can see this in
your head I can see the gears because
you're not just asking these questions
you're answering them in your head at
the same time that you're asking the
questions deny that the first denied yet
the next which I think attachments one I
have like one imagined answer for which
is the first location component yeah
which is what I think it could be this
way at a time when but like a second
land it's easy right
did you know how to do that right oh how
to change the oh I'm saying so
that hopefully has become so very easy
yeah okay I'm just saying it's harder to
get I can also imagine coming up with
algorithms that seem very HLN are tended
to be very neutral that would get
identical effects and that's why it hey
I think it's very interesting to study
more and see if you can like teeth out
in but B I'm not ready to like lead to
the conclusion that Google is
manipulating its result to influencer I
I don't know what you're doing but I
know how to track what they're doing and
I'm learning more and more about how to
automate the analysis of the data that
we're collecting and I know how to set
up systems like this so see I think but
I don't know what the answer is how do
you figure out what the bias that is
search result well we just thought we
that's a very good question that
question comes up all the time and I
sometimes I regret using the term bias
because it's a loaded term and I'm not
using it in a loaded way believe it or
not I realized by it sounds like
prejudiced and things like that
and I'm using it in the way psychology
researchers use the term was just omit
that it favors one perspective over
another and so when we have when we use
crowdsourcing to rate you know whether a
page is pro one candidate or another we
just we give them an 11-point scale goes
from 5 to 0 to 5 right here's candidate
and here's candidate B and we say read
the webpage and just tell us whether
it's favored and on this 11 points go
whether it's a vers candidate a and
candidate B so bias is an unfortunate
term the point is you can you can take
terms like that operationalize them
until you're satisfied so I don't think
that's what promise I don't even think
that bias per se is the problem I think
we're talking about a whole new world
that is emerging and this is I'm
actually working on a book on this side
they're trying to think ahead 10 or 20
years Wow is that impossible these days
but I think a whole new world is
emerging in which a sets of the sort
that I've been telling you about art
multiplied and so you know it's going to
be a game of ketchup and that's one of
the reasons why you have to have
monitoring systems in place because even
if you don't understand how those
apparently neutral kinds of stimuli
right but that you mentioned if you
don't understand how that's being used
to manipulate people looking at least it
can capture the information you can go
back and analyze the crap out of it and
maybe you can figure it out I think
that's the world that we're headed
toward one in which new technologies man
imagine how Google's home could be used
to manipulate or the new product that
Apple just announced but Apple has never
had this motive by the way because Apple
has a different business model Apple
actually sells products Microsoft
actually sells products I realize more
and more companies are moving in the
direction of Google's business model but
Google's doesn't sell any products not
really more than 90% of their revenue is
still advertising revenue there they use
cool-looking data collection platforms
to collect data and then they leverage
that data to make this this year they're
going to make over they'll have revenues
of over a hundred billion dollars so
Google is still the place you have to
watch and secondarily Facebook Google
currently controls five out of the six
billion platform applications in the
world and there's only one less than
that space that controls the other one
which is social media but what I'm
saying is Google you have to keep an eye
on you abut there many other companies
such as Google they're going to be other
companies doing other things that have
never been done before
you know these effects we're now
studying for effects that have never
existed before in human history
completely unprecedented almost entirely
invisible with which produce enormous
ships and people thinking all right
we're we've identified in our setting
for what do you think could there be
five
how many are there I don't know you know
we found and are studying for so does
that mean they're actually can I mean
they're actually 100 I don't know but I
do know this next year there'll be more
of those kind of effects than their
audition now so on
let me slowly shift to the advertising
will product is to find give you to some
of the emotions associated politics
there's an incredible battle between
search engines trying to give people
what they want and advertisers trying to
bump their stuff up there whether they
deserve it or not yes okay so how do you
decide what's fair in this work and in
terms of Paula fight rands late this
back into politics how am I going to
decide what's fair in that world you
know is your crowdsource evaluation I
can tell you what I am I can tell you
what I'm not okay I'll start with the
not I am NOT a lawyer I'm not a public
policy maker I am NOT a thought leader
or IANA
you know what I am I'm a researcher I'm
a really really good researcher the more
I've done research over the years the
more I realize I'm good I know how to
figure these things out and I love doing
it and that's but as far as I could go I
know I think that's cool though I think
that's pretty far I think your honor a
wonderful project okay the one thing you
haven't mentioned yet is keeping track
of the stuff that wasn't displayed so
you know whether what like when you try
and go back in here and evaluate
something as to whether you know the
stuff that you got we're supposed to
write sample well that's why we want to
we want to scale up the kind of thing
that we did if you scale it up large
enough you can trim you can keep track
of all kinds of look what look what
Brewster Cal's organization does you've
heard of the wayback machine I mean
Bruce I mean the Internet Archive takes
snapshots of the
entire Internet pretty much I don't know
think in the darknet but I mean at least
you know the Internet we most of us can
see so in if you have their resources
you could capture glass and roof and
whatever we want to capture ephemeral
information that's what we want to
capture that's what is normally done to
delete legal author and testament yeah
and one of the thing is we can capture
ephemeral information hold onto it
analyze it now or analyze it later
you